hails of guys my name is a Cherno and
welcome to the 10th
Sparky dev vlog so 10 dev logs that's a
nice number to have here and we've
actually achieved a lot since the first
dev vlog if you guys go back and take a
look at what Sparky was like at dev vlog
number 1 you'll see that the whole lot
has changed right the biggest thing that
has changed is this barking now supports
both directx and opengl but we've also
come just miles miles ahead where we
were last time with the 3d renderer and
we've we've we've just done so much work
so it's actually quiet it's actually
quite quite scary almost look back and
be like whoa like the engine back then
was barely anything right and now it's
actually now it's actually something
something something's there right it has
some weight to it now if I were to have
to rewrite this again I would be very
very annoyed because this is a lot of
work it's been it's been about a year in
fact since Sparky began so it's quite
quite a nice um it's coming along quite
well this devlog isn't really gonna be
about too much because what I've been
doing over the past week because I've
been preparing for a release ok now for
those of you who have been following
Sparky you know that when I kind of work
on Sparky and I'm kind of right in the
middle of a development cycle I don't
commit to github I just commit to like a
local kind of version er version err is
another version control system by the
way that you can check out there'll be a
link in the description below but I I
kind of keep a version a repository and
I use that all the time to kind of
transfer files between two computers and
mainly all of my kind of nightly
development right where the whole thing
is completely broken that happens on
that version of repository and so you
don't see that on github right and if
you guys do want access to that version
repository because it's usually just
something that I use then you can
actually do that by pledging five
dollars or more per month on patreon and
again the link to that is in the
description but once a month or so I
want to start doing releases on github
which is when I kind of synchronized
this this kind of working copy and all
of my local changes that I've done in
version II and I actually push that onto
the public github
and for those of you who don't know of
course Sparky is on github if you just
go to github.com 4/2 channel for Sparky
the link is in the description below
then you will you'll see this now this
is quite old if you look at this I think
it's about two months last commit was in
January well it's been more than two
months in fact so it's been a really
long time since the last commit and
again if you were to view the engine as
it was kind of back then my goodness
there are there are a lot of ah just so
much work has happened in fact I
challenge you guys to go and just
download the engine and take a look at
what it is now because what I do push
the code it'll be it's basically a
completely different engine it's just
crazy to think how much work is going
into this but anyway I will kind of
synchronize that up here so that's the
idea there's going to be a release in
March I promised you guys I would make
March and it turns out I'm actually
aiming for the 31st which is on Thursday
so the very last day of March is when
this should be uploaded to github okay
now in order to prepare for this release
I've been doing a few things so if we
just demo the game right now I'll show
you guys kind of what I've been working
on and my checklist of what I need to do
before I'm going to push it and the the
main thing here if we take a look at
this real quick so we've got this is
running just DirectX right now as you
can see there if I just kind of switch
the camera here so this is looking
pretty good where you have physically
based rendering here if we go to sandbox
and we just enable the test to D which
is so we'll be pushing that layer on top
of the 3d layer you should be able to
see both the 2d layer and the 3d layer
here we can just verify that both 2d and
3d is working correctly and actually
haven't tested this I hope it is it
should be yeah there we go right and
we've still got our mask as you can see
on the thing and if you kind of other
debug statistics that have come on that
have come up with the layer I if you
take a look at the I wonder why we're
not hitting basing here but anyway if
you take a look at this thing you'll
find let me just show off a 2d layer
real quick because it is in the way if
you take a look at the top right corner
which is kind of about debug layer stuff
you'll see a few things namely when this
okay namely you'll see of course the
memory usage which if you actually take
a look at it you'll see that it's not
growing so I fixed that memory leak and
you'll see the milliseconds per frame
because of course you can see that we
are at vsync which is 60fps but this
milliseconds per frame is actually how
long it takes to draw everything not
including the actual swapping the
buffers okay because of course that will
include fee sync and waiting for vsync
so um that's why we can't include that
but yeah so basically all the actual
drawing to the buffers that DirectX will
do and all that'll draw calls everything
from start to finish of a frame is what
this milliseconds display here shows so
you can really see how fast it is which
is not very fast at all now in fact I
think that if I launch OpenGL now you'll
see that it's around that let's do that
let's quickly switch this to OpenGL
there are some things that I need to fix
up with the opengl PBR shader as well
the DirectX one is generally a lot
better at the moment I think this won't
even work that's great why why are you
sad um I must have been right in the
middle of something let's take a look at
this it's not happy with the radiance
why is it not happy with the radiance I
wonder why what was the error message
this is fun I'm gonna debug this right
in front of you guys
has no return statement on expected
reserve would return what this is
correct there oh but a letter a here
really is that was that the reason for
the error I think so
alright that's fantastic well that was
easy anyway if I take a look at this it
looks a little bit different looks a bit
darker and we have this black kind of
spot here in the middle of everything
that you'll notice and I'm pretty sure
that's because of the texture wrap mode
I think it said to wrap and it should be
clamp I'm not a hundred percent sure but
I think that's the reason because this
happened in DirectX as well but I fixed
that by setting the
the sampler to be on isotropic but
that's doesn't really matter but clamp
instead of wrapping I don't know I
minded to provide you that for in jail I
think I did that on Reverend gelatin
worked properly but anyway you can see
that the OpenGL implementation roughly
works
look at the frame time that is so fast
DirectX will be that in maybe even a bit
faster
the reason it's about seven to eight
milliseconds right now on DirectX is
because I put in the base implementation
of DirectX right there are so many
optimizations I could do the worst thing
that I'm doing in DirectX right now is
I'm actually every for every single draw
call that I'm doing I'm actually calling
you know like set vs use a uniform
buffer which in the shader actually Maps
the resource you never want you want to
do this as as rarely as possible because
this actually takes up a sizable chunk
of time like you could measure the
amount of time that this takes up and
I'll do some I'm I'm not gonna do some
profiling in front of you guys now but
trust me this is terrible so ideally
what would happen is materials would
actually have you know these buffers in
them right so basically materials
actually maintain direct tax constant
buffers and then what happens is that
rather than mapping this every time
rather than the shader having one
constant buffer or however many positive
buffers you have in your shader in the
actual shader class and having to map
and unmount that all the time what you
do is you kind of delegate that off to
the material and then the material just
sets certain buffers is active in
certain slots right kind of like what we
have with with I imagine this is
somewhere here anyway when we actually
assign the buffer I actually just don't
even know what that is but anyway well I
guess they're dead okay over here right
so this is where we set all of our
constant buffers right you only kind of
do that you only s'what yeah you're in
this quit you switch out the constant
buffers rather than switching out that
data that is probably the primary reason
why this is so slow okay so once I think
that it'll definitely be able to
possibly anyway so DirectX by no means
is optimal
in fact I think OpenGL is not really
optimal OpenGL doe is very close to
being optimal compared to draft ax
because I've been gel forces the thing
that I've been working on for about a
year so that implementation is rather
good and you can see how fast it is
which is pretty awesome indeed it's very
very fast less than a millisecond per
frame at times which is fantastic for a
PBR shader I mean I know I know that
we're not really doing too much work
doesn't really not not like there's
probably one two three and there's how
many of them ten I think one two three
four five yep dance so there's 23 draw
calls happening as far as the the bass
sing goes I guess the skybox is another
drill call and all the text I'm not
counting so they're they're up and
that's not using the PBR head or anyway
so there are 23 draw calls with the PBR
shader they're really not that big
though but but you can see that it's
running very very quickly so I'd love to
create some nice scenes for this maybe
you guys can actually do that and I'll
definitely start involving you guys a
lot more because because of a few things
are gonna happen that I'm gonna show you
in a minute okay
first thing is though you really need to
be following this body trailer right
there's a link in the description
bittley's a full slash Sparky trailer
this is like a this is like a kind of a
road map ish it's more of like a task
kind of handler right it's kind of like
JIRA I'm using it kind of like Jarrow if
you guys have heard of that that's
basically like an issue tracker I'm kind
of using it a little bit like that
because it's free to have open up like
this to like opened up like this to the
public but basically this is both a list
of things that I'm currently working on
a list of things that are planned and
stuff like releases up here has a
checklist which I when I'm working I
have this open on that check stuff off
as soon as I do it which has a list of
all the stuff that I need to do before I
can basically ship this version of
Sparky right so we have you can see how
much I've done the big thing again that
I did was the Ford render memory leak
which was tied in with convert Ford
renderer to use system uniforms so the
actual forward renderer now as you'll
see has been expanded quite a bit and
there is there there was a lot of kind
of stuff going on here so when we
actually would as a begin scene now and
all that does is mem copies no
allocations whatsoever right there
is still be the submission here which
does push this into a vector and that
that does cause allocations
unfortunately because the standard
vector class is not very well written
for video games but anyway um will will
definitely will definitely switch that
out event sometime in the future to use
our own data structure that doesn't
allocate like crazy but you can see that
this is this has been switched out quite
a bit now this is funny as well one of
the things that I haven't done those
material rent flags so for example
should these should the material be
rendered with death testing on or death
testing off right what blend mode should
the material be rendered with all of
that kind of stuff is what our material
render flag is right it's basically a
flag that you have in the material which
tells the renderer how to render it now
we don't have that which is why you see
this comedy here where it says if I
equals 0 disabled death testing
otherwise enable it right and that is of
course for the skybox so you'll notice
that the skybox which is what we have
right over here is the very very first
thing we added the same so it is it is I
equals 0 and it is rounded with death
testing off so stuff like this is
exactly why materials need to have
render flags because otherwise yeah
there's like we should just be able to
be like hey skybox material rendered
with dev testing off and of course it
should do that automatically but same
same thing applies to stuff like blend
modes though definitely yeah so that's
another big thing that I have to do
everything else like there's a bit of
there's a few bugs here and there I'm
not really true like like bug bugs like
there are some bugs that I really like
fixed to fix texture 2d map generation
DirectX that stuff is kind of being
shifted off to the end of the list might
not even make the release but all this
easy stuff like m'children Flags needs
to get out that's probably the only a
big feature the rest is just you know
tidying yourself up like fixing some
compiler warnings reorganizing through
the filters in Visual Studio removing
journal graph because that well first of
all doesn't work and B should not be in
the solution and then I remove old
OpenGL specific file so we used to have
this like SP OpenGL like buffer and
some of these don't even exist this I
think that actually might still be used
but like all this stuff what we have
these they're not being used anymore
they were used back when my idea for
having to api's would be this low level
which of course is a terrible idea
and I don't know why even consider that
and then like this kind of stuff just
removing all this all this stuff so
there's that's really all that I have to
do and then you then it'll be up on
github and you guys will be able to play
with and I'll definitely do a video when
that happens because that's gonna be a
really big occasion and that should be
in a couple days here in like three days
so anyway that's pretty much gonna wrap
up this video I'm not gonna talk about
to like I'm not gonna talk too much
about what's gonna happen next and
what's gonna happen in April as far as
Sparky goes because I really want to
involve you guys a lot more with that so
really when we come up to that and when
you guys actually start using the engine
I'm gonna do a few things first of all
I'm going to start accepting pull
requests okay so if you want to
contribute to Sparky then I would
absolutely love you guys to do that okay
so of course right now no point this
stuff is very out of date very stale but
when this kind of gets synchronized more
or less with when I upload this code to
github yeah definitely pull requests all
that stuff and want to start accepting
them because the API is more or less
becoming stable or more stable at least
than it was over the last year I'm also
going to probably start up a cool series
maybe I am not a hundred percent sure if
the engine is really that ready yet but
where I actually try to make a game
because of course one of the most
important things where the game engine
is that it's easy to make games with and
I have no idea I have no idea of Sparky
is like that until I actually start
making a game and of course if you guys
want to start making your own games with
Sparky just just to play around with of
course I wouldn't recommend it for
anything serious because it's not ready
yet
but all that stuff then that that's not
the series that I'd love to love to
start up anyway so it's gonna it's gonna
be it's gonna be a nice kind of
community thing that we're gonna start
up here over the next month which should
be a lot of fun
and yeah and we'll probably start
working on some tools as well I really
want to make a level editor because I'm
getting a little bit annoyed by
having to you know set up massive kind
of massive scenes here and all that
stuff and just that's getting a little
bit annoying and it should be shouldn't
be too difficult to set up a little
level editor we'll need to have a
civilization willing to write some kind
of salvation library first as well which
is why it is on the Trello as as
critical because this is really really
I'm gonna co-op soon and then of course
when we do do that we'll have to make it
we'll have to finish that see a live
generator as well this is being moved to
probably critical as well because we
need to be able to generate a CLI code
so that we can actually because a level
editor that will make will be in c-sharp
using WPF this is gonna be Windows only
unfortunately for all of you
Linux people and math people who want to
use Sparky it the runtime will support
Linux and Mac but not the tools I'm not
going to support that just because I
mean I'm one person and there's there's
no way I'm gonna support three platforms
especially if I never ever plan on
actually making games on any other
platform on Windows so of course this is
a this is a public repository on github
so feel free to you know port this to
Linux to whatever you want in fact if we
could start getting people actually
testing this Sparky code on Linux and
Mac that will be fantastic anyway I'll
give you guys the details once that
begins but it should be a lot of fun and
if you did enjoyed the video please the
like button if you want to support a
development Sparky patreon is the best
place to do that you can become a patron
or save code more frequently and not
have to wait for all these github
releases but anyway I hope you guys
enjoy this video if you did like button
is of course below if you didn't like
the video feel free to hit the dislike
button and leave a comment saying why
and I'll see you guys next time goodbye